mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen und noch
eine letzte frage ist eigentlich alles
ok mit dir ich meine letzter zeit nervt
und alles fand ich immer etwas komisch
kann ich verstehen die frage viele ja
ich weiß gar nicht was ich dazu sagen
soll
[Musik]
willkommen waren ein video ja leute ich
hoffe euch geht's gut ich muss erstmal
sagen okay also vorweg mir ist
aufgefallen ich habe schon wichtig
solange kein fragen und antworten wieder
mehr gemacht in konnten wir schon so
lang eine falle stellen deswegen gibt es
heute
ich muss mich für das ganze megabyte ich
bin gerade auf jeden fall mega im stress
gestern und kann jetzt kein mega
aufwendiges video produzieren
dafür kommt donnerstag wieder was cool
ist super
also das habe ich noch vor und mehr
wollte ich gar nicht sagen ich würde
sagen der bock gehabt auch noch frank
war die video zu leisten drinnen dann
machen wir das und jetzt zu wahren was
ihr mich so gefragt habt ich bin
gespannt
let's go ach ja und unbedingt auf netze
längster folgen ganz wichtig so die
mehli fragt mit vier jahren hat dein
erstes handy bekommen sehr gute frage
ich habe mich gerade mal ein bisschen
hingesetzt und habe überlegt habe
zurückgerechnet und zwar habe ich das
glaube ich mit zehn jahren in der
fünften klasse bekommen und war das von
11 das wort jeden fall so ein samsung
schiebehandy man konnte das einfach
hochschieben und zwar wirklich durch
stolz auf die handys war so geil
eigentlich so mein erstes handy hatte
krasses gefühl kennt wahrscheinlich
selber abholen
heutzutage wird einem ja schon iphone 7
in die wiege gelegt so zu sagen ich
fühle mich immer wenn so ein
zehnjähriger kommt und einfach ein
iphone 7 plus hat und ich habe nur ein
iphone wegputzt so die nächste kommt von
anna sie fragt kannst mal eine autogramm
tour machen sehr gute frage
ich wollte was immer schon mal machen
und ich hab mir sage dass dabei eine
million abonnenten setzt du dich waren
die planung dass das umsetzbar ist also
ein bisschen müssen noch warten aber
vielleicht erreicht dass wir im laufe
des nächsten jahres oder so keine ahnung
werden wir sehen es kann ja mal so viel
passieren ich gebe mein bestes auf jeden
fall
und ja keine ahnung würd sagen eine
million ist so eine coole marke dann
kann ich sagen eine million abonnenten
tour krasser name
bei alex so alex wie zeichnen fragt
erste schöne grüße ganz tolle fan page
kann man auf jeden fall vorbei schauen
so sie fragt was ist deine
lieblingsmarke von der kleidung her
also ich muss sagen ich trage extrem
gerne sachen von jordans 16 uhr oder
police ganz gerne auch von adidas für
mich auch cool habe ich mir jetzt
gestern auch ein paar neue sachen
gekauft
meine eigene marke weit ist auch ein
super ding und was sich jetzt auch noch
mal kurz an sprechen kann weswegen ich
in letzter zeit jetzt auch nicht so viel
zeit hatte und zwar kann ich euch jetzt
endlich verkündet zu 100 prozent kommt
im verlauf der nächsten wochen ich hoffe
in zwei wochen schon mein motto ist dran
am logo wie das ganze aussehen soll was
da geben soll und so weiter juli sei
leise tage schneller also design was du
alles geben soll rucksack handy höhen
und so weiter politisch police und
moody's sind übrigens nicht das gleiche
glaube ich deswegen da könnt ihr euch
auf jeden fall freuen
und das sind so meine favorisierten
kleider warten so die nächste frage
marie fragt hast du eine peinliche
alkohol sorry da habe ich erst mal kurz
überlegt alex kannst du das b3 nehmen
und ich hab mir gedacht warum nicht
vor einem jahr hätte ich wahrscheinlich
nicht gesagt wird ein frischer es egal
ist schon so lange her okay war selbst
lange auf jeden fall ich war mit 17
glaube ich hier in köln in einem club
und wir waren zu fünft haben gedacht ich
komm' heute muss wir uns die sau
rausgelassen werden und wir haben von
lohse gemietete und hat dann auch eine
xxl alkohol fleisch zu bekommen ich weiß
auch nicht wie ich das mit 17 oder wie
wir das mit 17 auf die reihe bekommen
haben aber irgendwie hat es funktioniert
ja uns kleine alex dass sie sich dann
eher heute musste immer ordentlich
reinhauen ich hab dann so die ersten
drei gläser getrunken habt ihr nicht
viel gemerkt ich war glaube ich was
alkohol angeht eigentlich schon relativ
schlau also ich könnte meine grenzen
irgendwie aber an dem abend nicht
vielleicht wird mir auf was ins glas
getan ich glaube zwar nicht aber auf
jeden fall hatten nach den ersten ring
leser nicht viel gemerkt dann habe ich
ordentlich noch nachgebessert und
plötzlich
wenn das meine eltern ist katrin schöne
grüße und plötzlich kam ich ohne spaß
gar nicht mehr klar das ding irgendwie
innerhalb von 15 minuten
ey ich dachte was geht ab und ich bin
darum gehört und irgendwann kam dem
türsteher mir das weiß ich so weit noch
und der meinte hey du bist echt zu
besoffen sorry wir müssen nicht
rausschmeißen
ich habe überhaupt nicht geteilt ich
hatte so eine verzerrte das ding halt
nur diese fahrkarte hatte ich kurz
vorher kumpel gegeben der dann irgendwie
weg war ich stand dann so aussehen und
wusste gar nicht was ich machen soll ich
kann wirklich gar nicht klar ja
irgendwie bin ich dann da rausgekommen
und bin am nächsten morgen im hotel
aufgewacht und ich wusste nicht mehr
viel ich habe da nur aus dem nichts
gehört
ich habe mich mehrmals übergeben und so
was alles will ich gar nicht genau noch
eingehen sowas kann auf jeden fall mal
passieren
man ist immer im nachhinein schlauer man
lernt aus seinen fehlern und es sollte
auf keinen fall nochmal passieren also
leute immer aufpassen trinkt niemals so
viel das ist das macht uns die nächste
frage ist wie viele frauen hast du mal
geklärt
klar will ich weiß es nicht kann ich dir
nicht sagen ich habe nicht genau
mitgezählt aber es war nicht wirklich
viele ich kann ehrlich sagen ich bin
mehr so ein beziehungsmensch und
deswegen bin ich jetzt bist du der der
unbedingt jedes jahr 20 verschiedene
frauen aufreißen muss merckles dazu
nicht sagen und noch eine letzte frage
ist eigentlich alles ok mit dir ich
meine in letzter zeit eines tabs und
alles fand ich immer etwas komisch kann
ich verstehen die frage viele ja ich
weiß gar nicht was ich dazu sagen soll
also erst mal kann ich sagen mir geht es
soweit
relativ gut mir geht es gut also ich
kann es nicht beschweren leben läuft
alles eigentlich ziemlich gut es ist das
nicht so ein paar sachen gerade die kann
ich euch noch gar nicht sagen also ich
will da jetzt wirklich gar nichts
überstürzen wartet einfach ab
ich versuche mein bestes zu geben die
besten videos zu bringen wie zeit
möglich ist auch wenn ich immer drei
oder vier die woche meistens ja sogar
vier in letzter zeit immer gelungen die
meisten von euch wird wahrscheinlich
ähnlich interessieren aber ich kriege so
viele nachrichten von wegen er ist alles
gut blabla
lass dir bitte einfach zeit wenn ich
irgendwie der meinung wenn er jetzt kann
man darüber maria oder so dann wird das
natürlich von meiner seite auskommen
kommt auch in zukunft sicherlich kurz
was zu halten sie gesagt macht euch
bitte keine sorgen lebt einfach euer
leben schaut meine videos ich bin in
meinen videos immer verdammt glücklich
so komme ich mir über also die macht auf
jeden fall megaspaß wird wieder ein
video zu drehen und ich bin auch im
großen und ganzen immer noch sehr
glücklich keine ahnung müssen statt
schwer das alles auf den punkt zu
bringen
wartet einfach ab geht mit zeit lässt
sich mit allen möglichen sachen in ruhe
was meine privatsphäre angeht oder so
ich hoffe das versteht ihr alle an sie
müsse nicht jeden tag schreibe auf alles
okay ist und irgendwelche theorien
aufstellen musste nicht so gut laufen
könnte ja das war ich auch mal kurz an
sprechen
alles ist cool er wollte so vielleicht
mal dazu ich hoffe es hat euch
unterhalten dieses video ihr seid ja so
einiges lauer
was mich angeht und wir sehen uns
natürlich wieder über worden
dort wird mal wieder ein bisschen filou
in die pfanne gehauen zu schauen
ich freue mich dabei sind auch leicht
von der nächste partner fenster wird in
uns haut rein